we have to end off with some good vibes
courtesy of one of our favorite
Hollywood hunks Jason Momoa this is
amazing I don't think you're ready for
this one Aquaman himself joined James
Corden on The Late Late Show where Jason
explained he was too busy filming over
the past couple of months so
unfortunately he couldn't spend this
summer with James yeah and while they
didn't get to enjoy a hot boy summer
they sure made up for it by reliving a
Summer full of memories in a hilarious
Montage where they traveled to Italy
Paris and even enjoyed a nude barbecue
you should never barbecue nude it's so
dangerous isn't it just saying all right
it was good seeing everybody we'll see
you next time
don't do it
[Music]
[Applause]
stop
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]